>>Douglas: We're very diverse.
We have all the same issues that
any high school in America has,
but by offering kids
options that they can see
that what they're learning
is relevant beyond the walls
of the high school, is what's key.
>>Narrator: In 1995, Laguna
Creek opened its first school
within a school career academy.
The Manufacturing Production
Technology Academy.
>>Student: You designed that
one in Engineering class?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Student: You lucky son of a gun.
>>Dave: Today we're
launching rockets.
Students have designed these rockets
on a CAD program called, RockSim,
and so that program allows them
to test a number of parameters.
The point is to help
them learn the physics.
The fun part is that they get
to design and launch a rocket.
>>In order to determine the height,
we have one known angle,
so theta here.
>>Narrator: Today, Laguna
Creek has three academies.
Each academy accepts
about 70 students who move
through the curriculum as a group.
They take project based
college prep courses
that integrate core academic
subjects with technical training.
>>Dave: We have students
in this physics class,
everything from special ed.
students to AP students,
and everything in between.
And when they've taken the
standardized tests in the past,
they tend to do much better
than the general population.
It seems that they
understand the material better
if we're not just focused on taking
lecture notes and doing calculations.
So when they can experience it,
it seems to make a big difference
in their level of understanding.
>>Chris: The wind turbine uses the
fan's power to create electricity,
and then when we flip the
circuit, it will power the pump.
>>Narrator: The Green Energy
Technology Academy, or GETA,
is dedicated to the burgeoning field
of alternative energy production.
>>Chris: And I get to,
like, work with my hands,
and think about problems and work
through them, more than just, like,
sitting at a desk and writing down.
It's more fun, and you get
to learn in a better way.
>>Eric: So those things that
you've found should be able
to increase the growth.
>>In designing the curriculum,
I looked at a couple of things.
What were the types of renewable
energy that existed, wind and solar
and biofuels, and geothermal,
and hydroelectric,
are all types of renewable energies,
and then from there, I said, okay,
of these different types, which
would allow for pretty decent hands
on projects, and that really guided
my development of the courses.
>>Sobe: This is our go-kart.
We got a grant from
Lowes for 200 dollars
to get all the supplies,
the metal, the wood.
We researched design,
how to make it efficient,
and we spent about nine
weeks designing it,
planning it, and making it.
It's been great.
You know, there's been a
lot of time and effort,
blood and sweat that
went into our work.
It's been quite an experience.
>>Eric: Each project is
a team driven project.
You know, each team has a project
manager, a technician, an auditor
and a recorder, and each day, each
student is given a job they need
to fulfill for that
particular project.
They take pictures and video
and put together a PowerPoint
that chronicles their
work throughout the term.
At the very end, they always
present to a panel of experts
that we bring in, that's
related to that field.
>>Chris: This is a closed
loop photobioreactor
and it's a very good
apparatus for growing
about 40 gallons worth
of algae for testing.
>>Narrator: The academy has partnered
with several green businesses,
who provide expertise
and mentorships.
>>Chris: It's our responsibility as
industry people who are out there
on the cutting edge, to be mentors
and help the students understand
where the industry is going,
and give them some of the tools
to help them succeed in that.
>>Reanna: How does this
help our job market?
>>Chris: So there's a lot of jobs
that are created from the production
of the material, and then
there's lots of jobs created
from the pipe fitting and
these kinds of things that need
to be done, to put them together.
>>Narrator: In addition to
offering career options,
the green academy kept Reanna
from dropping out of school.
>>Reanna: My mom would go to
work, and I would just stay home
when she went to work, because she
would leave before I even woke up,
and she wouldn't know I didn't go to
school, because she wouldn't be home
until after I got out of school.
So it was just basically easy
to stay home, and I did that for
about six months, and
then I started, like,
seeing what Mr. Johnston's projects
were about, and I started just coming
to fourth period, which
was Mr. Johnston's class,
and then I started coming
to third and fourth period,
and then gradually started
working my way up to first period.
And I currently maintain a 4.0--
almost my whole junior year.
>>Douglas: When you take a look
at academy versus a general ed.
population, you find that the
academy students, generally,
are academically stronger, they test
better, the attendance is better,
everything has increased positively.
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Education,
go to edutopia.org.